a prominent liberal Republican who
happens to be running for president in
is insistent that the Joe Biden Hunter
Biden corruption investigation is not
going to make one little bit of a
difference come November well look uh
Hunter Biden's not on the ballot and I
you you know that I predicted weeks
before the hunter Biden plea was
rejected that it would be rejected
because it was a completely one-sided
plea deal in favor of Hunter Biden now
he's going to face the same type of
trial
um that Donald Trump's going to face and
and here's the interesting part uh you
know some of those voters who say that
say the hunter Biden thing matters but
Donald Trump's doesn't
um that's just wishful thinking the fact
is that the two people who would be on
the ballot if we nominated Donald Trump
will be Donald Trump and Joe Biden not
Hunter Biden and the fact is it's the
conduct of the people who are running
for office it's going to matter the most
we may find out more about President
Biden in the months to come
there it is you see he hints at the
complete undercutting of his argument
right there at the end because what he
says is look this is this match is going
to be about Trump and Biden if Trump is
the nominee it's going to be Trump
versus Biden and no one's going to care
about Hunter Biden because Hunter
Biden's not on the ballot
sure but the probe into Hunter Biden is
also not about Hunter Biden
that's why we're not really all that
concerned about his sex crimes that's
why we're really not all that concerned
about his drug crimes
they're good tabloid material but that's
not really what Republicans are focused
on
we're focused on the political
corruption we're focused on the payments
from Ukraine we're focused on the
payments from China we're focused on
payments from other powers around the
world that we're paying Hunter Biden
because Hunter was selling his father's
influence as the vice president
we're interested in that Hunter Biden
corruption because it implicates Joe we
don't even need to guess at this we've
got we've got the whole hard drive full
of text messages and emails connecting
Joe to these crimes we've got a
handwritten letter from Joe Biden to
Hunter Biden's business partner Devin
Archer a handwritten letter that proves
that Joe Biden invited Devin Archer to a
meeting with Xi Jinping the president of
China or it may have been the previous
president of China at the time because
this this goes back now like a decade
the we've got evidence after evidence
after evidence and now we've got Victor
shoken who is the prosecutor that Joe
Biden forced the ukrainians to fire
Victor shoken coming out and saying Joe
Biden was being bribed by Ukraine
I have no doubt that there were illegal
activities engaged in by uh barisma as a
matter of fact the criminal case had
been started before me it continued to
expand and flozewsky who at the time
held the post to minister and was the
founder and CEO of purisma started
bringing in people who could provide
protection for him Hunter Biden was
among them and the corruption Network
expanded as a result so yes to answer
your question there's no doubt in my
mind that purisma was engaged in illegal
activities had I continued to oversee
the purisma investigation we would have
found the facts about the corrupt
activities that they were engaging in
that included both Hunter Biden and
David Archer and others I do not want to
deal in unproven facts but my personal
conviction is that yes this was through
the case they were being bribed the fact
that Joe Biden gave away one billion
dollars in U.S money in exchange for my
dismissal my firing isn't that alone a
case of corruption
obviously it is and the clip that he's
referring to there Victor shulkin is
when Joe Biden publicly semi-publicly
because it was in a private event of the
Council on Foreign Relations but there
was a little camera in the back and
that's how this clip has gone viral Joe
Biden bragged about
paying the ukrainians a billion dollars
to fire the guy who is investigating the
company that was bribing him and his son
at least his son and according to the
text messages and emails that we've seen
would seem to suggest some of that money
a lot of that money was going to Joe
I remember going over convincing our
team our brothers to convincing us that
we should be providing for loan
guarantees and I went over right I guess
the 12 13th time to Kiev and and I was
going supposed to announce that there
was another billion dollar loan
guarantee and I had gotten a commitment
from poroshenko and from uh yatsenyuk
that they would take action against the
state prosecutor and they didn't so they
said they had they were walking out to
Prescott and said no I said I'm not
going to or we're not going to give you
the billion dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting the billion dollars I said
you're not getting a billion I'm going
to be leaving here and I think it was
what six hours I look I said I'm leaving
in six hours if the prosecutor is not
fired you're not getting the money well
son of a
got fired and they put in place someone
who was solid
someone who is solidly going to stop
looking into the company that was paying
my family a ton of money in bribes right
now go to cinch.com use code Knowles
picture the perfect Summer Night a warm
breeze on your face as you Lounge in
your favorite chair outside the grill is
sizzling with Juicy Burgers in the aroma
of the food is irresistible boy could
you imagine now
imagine what this perfect summer night
would look like if you went to turn on
the grill and your propane tank were
empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door on your
schedule and they require no long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you do not
have to wait around at home track the
order on the Cinch app from anywhere
whether you're grilling steaks or
lighting up the patio heaters on a cold
night cinches propane delivery service
ensures that you have the fuel you need
to make the most of every moment go
online to cinch.com or download the
Cinch app to order new customers can get
their first tank exchange for just 10
bucks with promo code nulls go to
cinch.com
or download the Cinch app use promo code
nulls kwles to get your first tank
exchange for just ten dollars is a
limited time offer you must live with an
essential service area to redeem it
visit cinch.com offer for details what
more proof do we need
we talk a lot about political corruption
because one we like to attack our
political opponents but two we just live
in a particularly corrupt time
and so we we take these accusations with
a grain of salt in the case of Joe Biden
there is no more proof that we could
possibly have
unless we saw a public venmo payment
from Ukraine to Joe Biden that said for
all of the corruption there is no more
proof that we could possibly have
we've got Hunter Biden talking about how
the big guy gets 10 we had Hunter Biden
texting his family saying that unlike
his father he's never going to make them
give give to him half his salary half of
their salary we've got the the financial
documents showing all of these payments
from foreign powers to the Shell company
set up by Hunter Biden and Devin Archer
we've got the letters connecting Joe
Biden to Devon Archer and obviously to
Hunter Biden we now know thanks to the
House Republicans that Joe Biden was
conducting business while vice president
under a pseudonym
but Robert Ware and Robert L
I forget to let Peters Robert L Peters
several pseudonyms that he was
conducting not just little pleasantry
kind of business but was setting up
phone calls with the president of
Ukraine just obvious rank corruption and
yet no one's going to touch this guy
meanwhile Donald Trump what as president
called the secretary of state of Georgia
to inquire about the obvious voter fraud
that had gone on and they throw him in
the can for that and they take a mug
shot first mug shot of a U.S president
in American history
it's we are so obviously
beyond the point of uh Law and Order of
a of a serious justice system that look
in a way I have a grudging kind of
admiration for the for the game that Joe
Biden is playing that guy is just a
hustler through and through a total
gangster okay he's he's not even really
trying to hide it all that hard the
people that drive me the craziest right
now though are the squishes
the ones who are trying to deal within
these issues as though they were serious
matters for abstract legal reasoning
well you know listen I'm opposed to
arresting the leader of the opposition
I'm not saying it's a good thing that
we're arresting former presidents but
did Donald Trump
on when he was on the phone did he call
between three o'clock and four o'clock
or did he call between five o'clock and
six o'clock did what was the exact
nature of the statement that give me a
break man they would throw this guy in
prison for jaywalking they would throw
this guy in prison for not jaywalking
he could walk across the crosswalk with
the walk light on and they would they
would change the video footage and say
that it was a stop sign okay we are so
meanwhile Joe Biden is is sending his
son around to shake down every four and
later on planet Earth and say my dad's
going to give you American influence and
everybody looks the other way and they
get crooked plea deals and they get
diversion programs and they get nothing
Nary even a slap on the wrist
I'm I'm not saying this to point out the
hypocrisy normal people people with two
brain cells to rub together see the
hypocrisy I'm I'm
I'm really mentioning this just to shake
the squishes out of their stupor we are
not living in a time of ordinary Law and
Order and people should recognize that
when it comes to the persecutions of
conservatives up to and including Donald
Trump but including hundreds and
hundreds at least more conservatives
than that boy what a great clip that was
huh now make sure you ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time